when did you realize you wanted to hone
your story
probably yeah when it needed an overhaul
you mean
yeah seriously you know i think there
are points in our lives where we get the
call but we deny the call
right so at 30 i had the call and i
denied it
and i just kept going along as i went
along
and then toward my late 30s my life was
not
on the track that i wanted it to be and
i said what's not working
you know i've had these breakups i you
know i get engaged i'm
but i don't follow through one of my
friends called me the runaway bride
right all the stuff i'm like what is the
one common denominator in all of this
oh that was not the answer i wanted
me right
and all these relationships that i'd had
i was the one common denominator
that wasn't working out what was going
wrong in me and once i had that
sort of epiphany that the buck stops
with me
and that i'm responsible for everything
the way i've manifested my own life you
know that was
everything i saw before me that was a
very sobering moment
now how do i get out of that quicksand
that i had been
consumed by over the years i didn't even
realize i at this point i was so far
under the quicksand i had a straw that
must have gone up like 10 feet to give
me air right
how do i get out of that without sinking
and so
i thought well okay i had a breakup i
was unhappy and
i said i'm going to create a mantra
let's see if this mantra is going to
help me get out of this because i'd
become a total workaholic that was the
other
aspect of my life that i hated i just
worked you know and traveled for work
and
i would be on the road and i'd be in a
hotel room and one day i looked around i
was like
is this what i want for my life this is
not what i want i'm lonely out here
i work with people i have big teams of
people and i'm completely unsatisfied
i'm connected with
no one that's how i felt i mean i have
really i have really good friends but
even them
when you're traveling all the time it's
hard to stay close
so i'd really look at my life and begin
to dissect it but in my personal life i
wanted to get married
but i was telling myself that i wasn't
worthy and somehow when i really began
to dig deep right
and so i created this mantra and i said
you know what
if i get married now
or when i'm 90.
it'll be okay or
or never i can't remember it was
something along those lines it's been a
while i've been married
12 and a half years now congratulations
yeah yeah yeah and um
so but i started this mantra because i
could hear the negative voice in my head
and i'm like who is that like where did
she come from and
how did this start well it didn't really
matter but what mattered was is that i
created a new groove
and that i began to
tell myself it's all going to be okay
if i believe that he's out there looking
for me too
right we'll find each other but i have
to get to a place where
that energetically i'm going to resonate
in a way
that he can find me we're like beacons
right dude
dude what kind of tone are we sending
out is this beautiful
clear church bell and is that enough and
yes it is
or is it some other kind of fuzzy
half-committed
signal which i was putting out before i
guess what i was finding some other
fuzzy
half-committed signal but when i began
to say this is who i am
and what i want to find in the world he
appeared he appeared really fast within
three months
and then there were new things to learn
right so the journey never stops
that's one of the things i'd like to say
about my speakers i have three speakers
right now
one is amy who's a friend um
and you know with everything that she's
been through
the with the losing her legs below the
knee
um but gone on to live an incredible
life as a snowboarder
she was on dancing with the stars uh
came in second i mean she's an amazing
woman
i have another speaker that i just
started working with danielle uh
umstead also on dancing with the star
she's legally blind and she's
a a paralympian as well and a blind
skier
she can haul down that mountain 20 70
miles an hour
i can't do that seeing okay and then i
have another speaker chris norton
who um had a football injury
in college his freshman year of college
and
that injury was spoiler alert stop the
video
right now if you want to look up chris
norton
and football and then watch his talk
and learn more about him but he had a
neck injury and is now a quadriplegic
you may have seen some of his videos
he walked for his college graduation
and he also walked for his wedding
so those videos have gone viral three
extraordinary people
that i feel a lot of pressure to help
with their stories
and to do justice with them because we
humans
tend to look at story and think oh
that's it i don't know what i would do
if you know i was blind or i couldn't
you know didn't have feet or i couldn't
walk
unassisted right i was in a wheelchair
uh
these people's gone they go on they've
gone on to live
rich and full lives their stories didn't
end there
they actually began there and i think
that's a fundamental difference
for people who get stuck after an injury
or
after because they'll tell me about
people that they've known where they're
not having the same lives because
they of their beliefs their deep-seated
beliefs that they haven't worked on
changing yet
but they haven't accepted where they are
resistance
is an insidious thing um and so i feel a
lot of pressure
to do right by those stories and to
elevate the stories to say
everybody you know it's not just this
moment that changed the course of their
lives their lives
they continue to have other moments that
are changing the course of their lives
and i think that's important in story
that one moment can be so big that it
can
overshadow the rest but to know that
that you are like these people as you
watch
them in the audience because they think
that they're superheroes the audience
often
and i'm always working in in cognizant
of that
to try to elevate that story in a way
that it isn't superhuman that it's human
like you
and you too are superhuman right if that
makes sense
so um i'm i'm very honored to work
with these individuals that are so
exceptional and beautiful
you